[MUSIC PLAYING]
ERIC BIDELMAN: All right,
hey everybody.
So we're here with a couple of
folks from the Geo Developer
Relations Team, and I'm
from the Chrome
Developer Relations team.
My name is Eric Bidelman.
I guess go ahead and
introduce yourself.
Tell the world who you are.
LUKE MAHE: My name's Luke Mahe,
I'm from the Sydney
office working on
the Maps Team.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: And much like
Luke, except my name is
different, my name is Chris, I
also work in the Syndey office
on the Maps Developer
Relations Team.
ERIC BIDELMAN: Cool.
And I'm on Chrome Developer
Relations, as I said, and we
just got done launching Santa
Tracker this year.
In years past, Santa Tracker's
been this thing that we've
done in the Geo developer
relations team, and this year,
we kind of beefed it up and we
want to talk a little bit
about the tech behind
what we worked on.
So who wants to show off
some cool stuff first?
LUKE MAHE: Hey, we can
start with me.
ERIC BIDELMAN: Start with you?
LUKE MAHE: Yeah.
ERIC BIDELMAN: You
got the goods?
LUKE MAHE: I got the goods.
ERIC BIDELMAN: All right.
LUKE MAHE: So what we got
here is Santa's village.
This is Santa's village and
it's just counting down to
when he takes off.
Christmas is coming up, and
he's going to fly around.
ERIC BIDELMAN: So this is the
web experience of this year.
This is much different than
last year, I would say.
LUKE MAHE: Yeah.
So this year, we've got a hold
a couple of components with
web, but we really went and
targeted modern browsers this
year and did some really
cool things.
So you can see we've got
a plane flying along.
You can do some fun things like
a change the time of day.
And you can also then
go and interact.
So we've got this whole village
which parallaxes as
you move across the screen,
which is kind of cool.
ERIC BIDELMAN: Actually,
how are you doing that?
Maybe explain a little bit.
LUKE MAHE: Yeah, so CSS
transformations.
Obviously, that's the best way
we found out the way to do
this instead of just moving
backgrounds and
that sort of stuff.
So we have a couple of divs and
we're just shifting them
left and right.
And the ones at the foreground
are really massive, the ones
at the background
aren't so big.
ERIC BIDELMAN: That's cool, so
they're just images with CSS.
LUKE MAHE: Just images
with CSS.
ERIC BIDELMAN: So see, it
turns out CSS is pretty
powerful these days,
if you haven't
played with it recently.
LUKE MAHE: Yeah, it's cool.
ERIC BIDELMAN: What
is the count down?
So that's until Santa arrives,
or what's going on there?
LUKE MAHE: Yeah, this is until
he arrives at his village and
about to take off.
So he's still gathering
all his toys and
that sort of stuff.
So he hasn't done
his flight yet.
ERIC BIDELMAN: That's cool.
LUKE MAHE: Yeah, well this
countdown's pretty cool.
ERIC BIDELMAN: How the
heck did you do that?
That looks complicated.
LUKE MAHE: Yeah, it was
kind of complicated.
So each digit is actually
four divs.
So I've got a back face div,
and then we've got the top
half of an image, the letter,
at the top, and we've got
another two at the bottom.
And so we've got one
transformation which moves
something halfway, and then
timed as another one starts to
finish it off, and then that's
how we get the back face, and
it just flips.
ERIC BIDELMAN: So again, just
a little bit of CSS.
LUKE MAHE: Just a
little, all CSS.
And if you don't have CSS
animation, so your browser
doesn't support it,
it just changes.
So it just works
ERIC BIDELMAN: That's cool.
It's really cool.
So is that being calculated
client side as far as the time
count down?
Or how is that?
LUKE MAHE: Oh, we have a special
magical Santa server
which tells us when Santa
is going to go off.
ERIC BIDELMAN: Oh wow,
did you work with the
elves on that one?
LUKE MAHE: We did.
We worked with them for a while
now to try to coordinate
the right time for
him to take off.
ERIC BIDELMAN: That's
cool, man.
All right.
LUKE MAHE: It's fun.
Some interesting things around
the village, like you can
click on the balloons and
they will fly around the
[INAUDIBLE].
ERIC BIDELMAN: So kids are
going to have a ball with
this, right?
LUKE MAHE: We hope so.
ERIC BIDELMAN: There's a
lot of interactivity.
Any sort of hidden gems that
you want to talk about?
LUKE MAHE: There's going to be
easter eggs throughout the
whole site, so I'm not going
to show a lot of them.
But we've got some fun things
like if we go along,
you can click on--
this is one of my favorite.
So you've got a little scene.
ERIC BIDELMAN: Oh, wow.
LUKE MAHE: Yeah.
So these are Santa's elves
at the moment testing his
reindeer in a wind tunnel to
make sure they're aerodynamic.
It's a lot of fun.
ERIC BIDELMAN: He looks
pretty aerodynamic.
LUKE MAHE: He does
look aerodynamic.
ERIC BIDELMAN: So is
this Canvas, or how
are you doing this?
Is this HTML5?
LUKE MAHE: This is all
CSS3 animations.
ERIC BIDELMAN: It's all CSS?
LUKE MAHE: All CSS.
The whole thing is all CSS.
ERIC BIDELMAN: Wow.
LUKE MAHE: Yeah.
There are a bunch of images
all over the place and a
couple of repeating images, but
just like the little dials
and everything is all CSS.
ERIC BIDELMAN: So why CSS over
something like Canvas, or SVG?
LUKE MAHE: Well, we wanted to
support a lot more browsers.
We wanted to easily fall back.
So if you didn't have
animations, they'd just stand
still, but it's still an
experience that you'll like.
ERIC BIDELMAN: So what
browsers can
folks enjoy Santa on?
LUKE MAHE: All modern
browsers.
And then for special stuff
like the interaction and
animations and that sort of
stuff, anything that supports
CSS3 and keyframe animations.
ERIC BIDELMAN: Cool.
Which is pretty good support
these days, as far as the
modern [INAUDIBLE] browsers.
LUKE MAHE: Yeah.
And if you don't have it,
it just falls back.
Let's find some other
fun things.
So there's this whole village
where you can explore some
really cool things.
ERIC BIDELMAN: So this is very
much more of an interactive
experience than last year.
Like last year, I think you get
to track Santa, know where
he is, and sort of see him
as he flies through.
But this is much more of like,
interacting, playing some
games is really cool.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: I'd say
it's much more playful.
Last year was more of a Google
Earth experience, where you
sort of track Santa in a sort
of realistic way, where this
is, I think it's more jovial.
ERIC BIDELMAN: Yeah.
LUKE MAHE: It's a bit more fun
before Santa takes off.
So you can explore
the village.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: The games and
the easter eggs are amazing.
LUKE MAHE: Speaking of games.
CHRIS BROADFOOT:
Oh you got one.
LUKE MAHE: Got a game here.
Got some sounds.
Yeah.
So here's a little Santa
racing game.
ERIC BIDELMAN: I think Paul
Lewis did this game, right?
LUKE MAHE: Yeah.
ERIC BIDELMAN: The infamous Paul
Lewis, who is big fan of
WebGL and has done a lot
of great stuff if
you're in that community.
This looks really fun.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: So how's
this one built?
Is this a Canvas?
LUKE MAHE: Yeah.
So we did a couple of
limitations with our games.
We did another one of
the games, which
was all done in CSS.
Let me just pause.
As much as we love the sound.
This one is actually
all done in Canvas.
So it's really smooth and fluid,
and we can do a lot of
cool things.
So we've got another game,
which if we're lucky,
we might show you.
And that was all done on CSS.
So we wanted to like, push the
boundary, but not always
concentrate on just
one technology.
We wanted to see if we
could do a couple
of different things.
ERIC BIDELMAN: You
might as well.
I mean, we have all this stuff
in HTML5 now that we can do.
And certainly, even more than
last year, I would say, and
every year it gets
more powerful.
So why not have a game with
awesome physics and sound, and
web audio API?
All the cool stuff.
LUKE MAHE: I can almost
drift Santa's sleigh.
ERIC BIDELMAN: You've clearly
been practicing.
LUKE MAHE: Oh, yeah.
Well, someone has
to test this.
ERIC BIDELMAN: This is
important QA testing.
LUKE MAHE: Yes.
ERIC BIDELMAN: Cool.
Is there anything else that
you want to highlight?
LUKE MAHE: Also, this
is the countdown
before Santa takes off.
And then I can actually
switch to once
Santa's actually in flight.
We can show what that's
about, if you like.
ERIC BIDELMAN: Let's do it.
I mean, that's what Santa
Tracker's all about, right?
Is actually tracking
to see where he is.
LUKE MAHE: So here's Santa as
he's actually flying around.
So we've got a dashboard
of Santa.
So we can see where he's flying
to, where he was, and
we can get some fun facts, like
presents delivered, and
what he's currently doing.
ERIC BIDELMAN: That's cool.
LUKE MAHE: Yeah.
ERIC BIDELMAN: And his little
status message updates when he
visits a new location.
LUKE MAHE: Yeah.
Yeah.
And then if you are kind of
bored of watching Santa for
the moment, you can
zoom out, and kind
of explore the village.
I mean, explore the
world, sorry.
And see all the locations
where he's been so far.
And you can click on these and
find out some fun facts about
that location.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Could
be educational.
LUKE MAHE: Yeah, a
bit educational.
You can see some cool photos.
You can go through the photos.
ERIC BIDELMAN: What is powering
all the photos and
everything like that?
CHRIS BROADFOOT: So we have a
content service that's built
on App Engine.
So we've basically aggregated
a whole bunch of content so
the photos come from Panoramio
via their API, and Wikipedia
have provided us content.
It's a Creative Commons.
So that's all served
up when you click
through to a location.
ERIC BIDELMAN: That's nice.
LUKE MAHE: And then we
also have Wikipedia,
which is kind of cool.
Santa's reading Wikipedia
on his Nexus 10.
ERIC BIDELMAN: Nice.
I see Santa's technologically
advanced.
LUKE MAHE: Yeah, he is.
ERIC BIDELMAN: He's got the
latest and greatest.
LUKE MAHE: Yep.
ERIC BIDELMAN: That's
very cool.
LUKE MAHE: Yeah.
And that will CSS3 as well.
ERIC BIDELMAN: I'm just
impressed with like, all the
cool CSS stuff that can
be done these days.
LUKE MAHE: Yeah.
So we can see some fun things
that right now, actually
Santa's doing.
ERIC BIDELMAN: And so the m
itself, the map is just, the
maps Google Maps.
LUKE MAHE: Yeah.
Just a Google Map.
We've styled it.
We've just got normal markers.
Santa's a marker.
See right now, he's delivering
presence.
He's having a lot of fun.
We can see the presents
delivered, and weather.
And all that sort of stuff.
And then we've got an Earth
button as well.
So you can watch Earth.
ERIC BIDELMAN: Oh, so Google
Earth is still part of that.
LUKE MAHE: Yeah, Google Earth
is still part of it.
So you'll sit there and watch
Earth, and go from there.
ERIC BIDELMAN: Nice.
Well, this certainly wouldn't
be possible without all the
work that Chris has done.
I know you've spent countless
hours on developing sort of
the, what are we calling it?
The Santa Service?
LUKE MAHE: Yes.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: It's all
about the children.
LUKE MAHE: It is.
ERIC BIDELMAN: Absolutely.
So do you want to talk a little
bit about sort of
what's powering?
So we have the web experience
that Luke has been showing.
All the sort of where
Santa's visiting.
All that information's coming
from someplace.
Where is it coming from?
CHRIS BROADFOOT: So all of the
things that, ways you can
track Santa run from this
App Engine app.
So that includes the web that
we've looked at, the Chrome
extension, which we'll
look at soon.
There's a Google Earth
experience, if you have Google
Earth on your mobile.
And there's an Android
app, as well.
So yeah.
These all come from an App
Engine app that basically
tells you where Santa is.
ERIC BIDELMAN: That's cool.
So it's a service that
scales very well.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Yeah,
very well.
LUKE MAHE: So it's built on
Go, so it's very fast.
We've paid a lot of attention
to caching, and making sure
that things run smoothly.
ERIC BIDELMAN: That's cool.
You have any code to show?
Do you want to give a little
sneak peak of the API itself?
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Nope.
ERIC BIDELMAN: OK.
So Santa's top secret?
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Yeah.
Top secret.
Yeah, I mean, it's probably
best described, I think.
So when you go to the website,
the service will tell you the
time according to Google.
So if you've got some computer
with a clock that's incorrect,
you're going to see where
Santa actually is.
So that's what happens first.
Then it'll go and
fetch the route.
So Santa's giving us his
itinerary ahead of time.
And everyone's synchronized
on that.
ERIC BIDELMAN: So
that serves as
powering all of the clients.
So the Chrome extension
that we haven't seen
yet, the web app here.
All the Android and
mobile apps.
So everybody theoretically,
you fire up the app under
these respective devices,
or these platforms.
And everybody's kind
of in sync.
That's really cool.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Yeah.
I mean, if you had them side by
side, the idea is to create
that realism that Santa's
actually in that place.
ERIC BIDELMAN: He's only in
one place at one time.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: That's true.
And he is real.
ERIC BIDELMAN: Absolutely.
So this is really nice, man.
This is definitely a way, way
cooler experience than last
year, I would say.
Much more to it.
Luke, do you want to show
the portion I worked on?
LUKE MAHE: I was going
to say, you know,
we've had all the glory.
Do you want to see--
we should show what
you've done.
ERIC BIDELMAN: So again, I
work on the Chrome team.
So we wanted to come out with a
nice little Chrome extension
that folks could use to sort of
experience and track Santa,
interact with the Santa
Tracker before he
takes off on his route.
And so we put together an
extension, a nice little
Chrome extension.
LUKE MAHE: Turn the sound
on, because you
added some cool stuff.
ERIC BIDELMAN: I do.
So I have a little click when
the tick tock, the countdown
timer flips its little bit.
So that's using Web Audio API,
if you guys are into the HTML5
audio scene.
Brand new API.
And what's kind of nice about a
Chrome extension is I don't
have to worry about browser
support, right?
I know my browser's--
LUKE MAHE: That would
have been nice.
ERIC BIDELMAN: Yeah.
So you guys couldn't,
unfortunately,
have the same guarantee.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: So what's good
about the Web Audio API?
What does that give us?
ERIC BIDELMAN: Web Audio
API is great.
I'm a big fan.
Essentially, you can schedule
sound at very precise times.
So in the case of something
like this countdown timer
where the digits are flipping,
Luke has a nice little library
that he wrote to do a lot
of this animation work.
And so he fires off an event,
and I just attach a listener
to that event, and then
call the Web Audio
API with a tick sound.
LUKE MAHE: The event
was Tick Tock.
ERIC BIDELMAN: I think it was
Tick Tock, yeah, which makes a
lot of sense.
Yeah.
And so actually,
it was really.
We got to share a lot of
the same code base.
I took your counter stuff, and
basically I just made a media
query out of it, right?
LUKE MAHE: This counter
is the exact same one
that's on the village.
ERIC BIDELMAN: Yeah.
So we didn't have to duplicate
any work there.
And same parallax the fact.
Did the little animations.
And the idea is that folks will
hit that Explore Santa's
Village big red button there,
and jump into the web app
experience and sort of do the
games, and all the other stuff
we built up.
LUKE MAHE: But if I don't want
to go to Santa's Village just
yet, is there some
other fun things?
ERIC BIDELMAN: You
don't have to.
I'm glad you asked.
So you're on Google.com right
now, and one thing you can do
it with Chrome extensions is
inject CSS and JavaScript and
HTML in the page.
So we have a couple of buttons
at the bottom.
And do you want to show
off [INAUDIBLE]?
LUKE MAHE: Yeah, which one
do you want to pick?
We'll click on it first.
ERIC BIDELMAN: Let's go
for the Blimpies.
LUKE MAHE: Go click
on the blimp?
ERIC BIDELMAN: Yeah.
So this is all very reminiscent
of all the assets
you saw on the web experience.
LUKE MAHE: So we
got the blimp.
ERIC BIDELMAN: We
Now he's injected on--
[HONKING]
LUKE MAHE: Wow.
ERIC BIDELMAN: So that's our
good buddy, the Web Audio API.
But yeah, I think it's going to
be really fun for kids to
play with and sort of see this
blimp on any website you kind
of come across using CSS filters
there, and animations
and transitions and stuff.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: So how can you
get the Chrome extension?
ERIC BIDELMAN: Yeah.
So you can go to the Chrome Web
Store to get the Chrome
extension, or we have a special
build of Chrome that
you can download, which also--
LUKE MAHE: Will have a
nice Chrome theme.
ERIC BIDELMAN: Has a great theme
for the holidays, and it
has the extension
pre-installed.
So you can get that and kind
of play with things,
and check them out.
LUKE MAHE: What else
have we got here?
Because I know that you did
some other cool things.
ERIC BIDELMAN: The snowflake
is really cool.
LUKE MAHE: The snowflake
is really fun.
ERIC BIDELMAN: That's
one of my favorites.
LUKE MAHE: Have a look here.
ERIC BIDELMAN: That's
very cool.
LUKE MAHE: That's very cute.
ERIC BIDELMAN: That's
very festive.
ERIC BIDELMAN: This is actually
using Canvas, which
is kind of--
LUKE MAHE: I'll turn
the sound off.
As much as we love that.
ERIC BIDELMAN: As festive
as it is.
This is using Canvas, and
essentially using some of the
properties with alpha
transparency in Canvas.
So if you want--
LUKE MAHE: What can
I do with this?
ERIC BIDELMAN: You can draw.
LUKE MAHE: I can draw with it?
ERIC BIDELMAN: It's a palette,
so why don't you write the
folks a message?
CHRIS BROADFOOT: So sort of
like you're painting on a
window, right?
ERIC BIDELMAN: Yeah, yeah.
And so there's an alpha
transparency property you can
set in Canvas, and then it just
basically bleeds through.
So the whole screen has been
filled up with Canvas.
I've injected a Canvas on the
page, and now we're--
CHRIS BROADFOOT: So I know how
to paint things in Canvas.
How do I do the arrangement?
How did you do that?
The arrangement?
Yeah.
It was tough.
I actually looked at a
few examples online.
Getting it right so that you
have sort of the snow that's
overlaying the page, and then
bleeding the pages through was
kind of tricky.
But it's basically just
mouse events, right?
And you subscribe to those.
And the touch events, and
then folks can paint.
Canvas just takes care
of everything,
which is really nice.
LUKE MAHE: And then I can
defrost my browser.
ERIC BIDELMAN: Defrost, yeah.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Goes away.
ERIC BIDELMAN: Well, in case
you want to do a Google
search, right?
LUKE MAHE: In case I
want to keep going.
Want to draw something new.
ERIC BIDELMAN: Yeah, yeah.
So it's cool.
The Chrome extension's very much
a companion to the other
stuff that you guys
have worked on.
LUKE MAHE: Was there any
interesting things you did
about, how getting it from the
Chrome extension and actually
putting stuff in the browser?
You know, communicating
between the two.
ERIC BIDELMAN: Yeah.
So you guys probably know this
better than I do, but the Maps
API in a Chrome extension is
pretty difficult to use,
actually, because the Manifest
v2, there' what's called the
content security policy
restrictions.
So you can't load in content
from external domains, which
means Maps API is kind of
out of the picture.
But we got to some interesting
things with the sandbox iframe
of the map.
And then kind of communicate
with the Maps API to update
Santa's position and whatnot
on the map, and sort of do
post message, and use iframe
communication.
So it was a little bit trickier
than it really needs
to be if you're building a web
app, but ultimately the CSP
restrictions are there to keep
users safe and secure.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Any
other details
in the Chrome extension?
ERIC BIDELMAN: What
else are we using?
RequestAnimationFrame.
Again, since it's a Chrome
extension, we can take
advantage of some of the latest
features for animation,
and requestAnimationFrame
is a great one.
LUKE MAHE: Yeah, and that's
exactly how we're doing the
Parallax as well where we're
doing the movement, we're
doing transformations, but
we're doing it in a
requestAnimationFrame.
ERIC BIDELMAN: That's cool.
And again, we're using Sass.
So for our CSS I think we all
chose that route just because
it's a lot easier to maintain.
LUKE MAHE: And that way, we can
have lots of individual
files so that you're just using
the countdown Sass file
that I was using as well.
So we're not duplicating.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: It helps with
cross-browser, vendor
prefixes, things like that.
ERIC BIDELMAN: And I think you
guys defined variables and I
imported them into my
stylesheets, and then--
LUKE MAHE: You just get them.
ERIC BIDELMAN: It
came for free.
LUKE MAHE: So when you're
working in a big team that's
kind of doing independent things
but sharing a lot of
stuff, that's a nice
way to do it.
So we're also sharing a
lot of JavaScript and
HTML as well, right?
ERIC BIDELMAN: Yeah.
LUKE MAHE: And we're doing the
standard Google stuff.
All that code is compiled
with Closure.
So, all minified.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: We had a lot
of hits, so we've got to
reduce the bandwidth.
ERIC BIDELMAN: So a lot of
people are interested in where
Santa is going.
LUKE MAHE: But one fun factor we
found when we were building
this on a high DPI laptop, the
performance when we first did
it was really quite poor.
And then what we did is, once we
replaced every image with a
high DPI version, the
performance improved
dramatically.
And it was because the browser
didn't have to spend time
scaling up the image
for the right size.
The performance was just
magically different.
ERIC BIDELMAN: Yeah.
So that was actually something,
I hadn't worked on
a big project yet that required
us to think about
high definition retina displays,
but these are
prevalent now, so we had to have
2x images all over the
place and make sure that it
looks good on the folks that
are having high displays.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: So do you guys
want to talk a bit about
mobile performance?
Because I know that they have
their limitations and they're
a lot slower.
LUKE MAHE: Well, the good thing
about that as well is,
because we're doing high DPI
images for this, we could just
give them to the mobile guys
as well for the native app,
because they could then
also render, use those
for high DPI images.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: So are there
any other performance tricks?
LUKE MAHE: Well, there's a
nifty one with the game,
especially to make the game work
well on a mobile device.
So instead of having your asset
and then saying display
none and then showing it when
you want, to keep it in the
GPU memory, just transform it
out of the screen space.
But it will still essentially
stay in GPU.
So then it doesn't have to keep
reloading that texture
and that actually improved
performance a lot for the
commonly used images.
ERIC BIDELMAN: And I know for
a lot of mobile devices, the
start up time for GPUs is
a little bit slower.
So you apply a CSS transform
or something and it takes a
little bit more time
and so you get
kind of a janky effect.
So doing something offscreen
is always the way to go.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: But yeah, I
mean, we're really happy to
offer mobile experience
this year.
Last year was not really much
to speak of, so we're
definitely paving the way.
ERIC BIDELMAN: Media queries
for the win, right?
LUKE MAHE: Yeah, totally.
When this gets too small as
well, we've got a nice,
responsive way that works well
for a mobile or small screen.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: No completely
separate experience.
All the same code, which
helps a lot.
ERIC BIDELMAN: Can you click
on the sun again?
That was really cool.
LUKE MAHE: I like it.
All the clouds are
done in CSS.
ERIC BIDELMAN: I wish I had
that the power to--
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Oh, I don't
want turn the balloon.
LUKE MAHE: Yeah, I've done the
balloon, but there'll be a
couple more easter eggs around
that you'll have to hunt for.
ERIC BIDELMAN: Very cool.
So you saved the
best for last.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Any Gangnam
style easter eggs?
ERIC BIDELMAN: TBA, maybe?
LUKE MAHE: Maybe we'll put some
easter eggs in here, but
you'll have to go
look for them.
We're not going to make
them easy to find.
ERIC BIDELMAN: Very cool.
So, Santa Tracker 2012.
Way, way more than last year.
Chrome, [? GEO ?], social,
Android, a lot of different
product areas and APIs
at play here.
So, very cool.
We all came together
and pulled it off,
which is really neat.
And App Engine as
well, I guess.
LUKE MAHE: Well, because
we all love Santa.
ERIC BIDELMAN: Everybody
loves Santa.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: And it's
all for the children.
LUKE MAHE: It is all
for the children.
ERIC BIDELMAN: Cool.
Well, thanks for joining
us everyone.
I really appreciate your time.
And check out Santa Tracker.
You can get Santa Tracker
on the Chrome
Web Store, the extension.
LUKE MAHE: And
google.com/santatracker for
the actual site.
ERIC BIDELMAN: For the site.
Then of course Google Play
for the Android App.